tal vez el político que genera más
divisiones en colombia álvaro uribe ha
conseguido la unanimidad con 82 votos
por el sí y 12 por el no el senado
colombiano aceptó este martes la
renuncia del ex presidente a su escaño
el trámite llegó menos de una hora
después de que el ex mandatario
anunciara su decisión de abandonar el
congreso en este anuncio uribe expresó
su apoyo a una reforma judicial
propuesta por su partido centro
democrático y que ha ganado fuerza en
medio de su juicio hago votos por una
reforma a la justicia que la despolitice
al cambiar el sistema de elección de
magistrados
esto deberían llegar a la alta corte
general madura
que haya disuelto las vanidades y
afianzado el apego a la rectitud su
renuncia se dio en medio de la
investigación en su contra por la corte
suprema de justicia por supuesta
manipulación de testigos en la cual fue
ordenada su detención domiciliaria el
anuncio había sido recibido como una
bomba política en el país presidente de
2002 a 2010 senador desde 2014
incansable detractor del acuerdo de paz
firmado con la guerrilla en 2016
álvaro uribe es también el padrino
político del actual jefe de estado ivan
du que tuvo el gran honor de trabajar
con álvaro uribe vélez en el senado soy
testigo de su amor por colombia su
entrega por los más vulnerables y su
compromiso por construir un mejor país
con su renuncia pierde el congreso- uno
de los mejores legisladores pero su
legado será imborrable en su anuncio
rive también denunció que las garantías
procesales habían sido violadas durante
su arresto domiciliario y que las
escuchas telefónicas que forman parte
del caso eran ilegales